this bottle this brand unique and busy
yet simple and standard you might have
seen it you might even use it but have
you ever read it
the dr. Bronner brand is the top-selling
organic soap company in North America
and if you look closely at the label
you'll see quotes from Jesus Einstein
George Washington you name it
you'll also read a lot about the moral
ABC the brainchild of dr. Emmanuel
Bronner the founder of dr. Bronner's
magic soaps born into a Jewish family in
Germany he emigrated to Milwaukee in
1929 and worked as a consultant for
various soap companies but his real
passion was philosophy he had a vision
for world peace and he called it moral
ABC its mission read in all we do let us
be generous fair and loving 2 spaceship
earth and all its inhabitants but were
all one or none all one basically he
wanted people to set aside their
religious and ethnic differences to find
common ground during World War two
Bronner began lecturing and spreading
his vision for peace and unity and he
started drawing crowds in 1947 during
one of his lecture tours Bronner was
arrested for giving a public speech
without a permit he wound up in a mental
institution he escaped and he made his
way to Southern California where he
declared himself a doctor rabbi and
alleged that he was Einstein's nephew it
was during this lecture tour that
Bronner began giving his family's soap
away he quickly realized people were
only coming for the free soap and
leaving before the lecture so Bronner
started printing his scriptures and
sticking them onto the bars and just
like that dr. Bronner's magic soap was
born
you